Blindflug hat der Gesundheitsminister
den Zustand genannt in dem Deutschland
durch das Jahresende steuerte kaum
belastbare coronazahlen das hält ihn von
einer düsteren Schätzung nicht ab wir
arbeiten jetzt ja an der also
Verfeinerung der Datenlage ich habe
damit ja sofort begonnen und bin so auch
zu dieser Abschätzung gekommen dass die
tatsächlich Inzidenz derzeit zwei bis
dreimal so ist wie die ausgewiesene
Inzidenz nur eine Woche später sind die
Zahlen noch immer nicht valide was ich
aber abzeichnet so düster wie der
Gesundheitsminister die Lage
eingeschätzt hat war sie wohl nicht
besser als man befürchten musste sagt
der Kanzler wenn man genau hinhört
obwohl die Lage durch all die Maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben besser ist als
man befürchten musste wissen wir dass
die neue
unicronvariante dazu führen wird dass
die Infektionen zunehmen werden auch
Professor Bertram Heusler Direktor des
unabhängigen
gesundheitsinstitutsiges geht davon aus
dass durch Omicron die Infektionszahlen
steigen wenn er sich über die Zahlen
beugt kann er die Grundlage für
Lauterbachs Schätzung aber nicht
erkennen
also davon auszugehen dass wir derzeit
zwei bis dreimal so viel Fälle haben das
halte ich jetzt aber auch wirklich für
Kühen wir sehen das ja hier das ist ja
ein paar Tage später wir es kommt jetzt
wieder zu einem Anstieg und wir bewegen
uns jetzt sicherlich auf dieser auf
dieser Kurve nach oben aber wir sind
vielleicht hier und nicht hier oben da
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
Häusler und sein Institut betreiben ein
eigenes pandemie-monitoring Datenlücken
sind glaubwürdigkeitslücken sagt er auch
Christian karagierides der die Regierung
im Expertenrat berät hält exakte Daten
für unerlässlich um
Grundrechtseinschränkungen zu begründen
also ich glaube grundsätzlich ist es
jetzt ganz wichtig wenn wir auf
kontaktbeschränkungen gucken dass wir da
wirklich auch eine definitive Datenlage
brauchen wirklich genau wissen müssen
wie viel omegon-fälle haben wir zu wie
viele Hospitalisierung für die wie viel
ungeimpfte betrifft sie auch gerade in
Deutschland und das ist für so eine
eingreifende Maßnahme wie
kontaktbeschränkung extrem wichtig und
doch kommt es bei den Zahlen mit den
pandemiepolitik gemacht wird immer
wieder zu Verzerrungen Ungenauigkeiten
Fehlern Beispiel 1 die
hospitalisierungsrate seit November ist
die hospitalisierungsrate einer
politische Kategorie also die Zahl der
hospitalisierten covet-fälle pro 100.000
Einwohner innerhalb von sieben Tagen und
Länder sind deshalb bereit zu einer
flächenden
flächendeckenden Anwendung von 2G 2g+
und weiteren Maßnahmen wenn es die
hospitalisierungsinsidenz in drei
Schritten
369 erfordert
Problem die Inzidenz ist oft verzögert
weil nicht tagesaktuell gemeldet wird
und sie ist verzerrt denn viele
Krankenhäuser melden auch Patienten mit
nebendiagnose Corona einer Recherche der
Welt am Sonntag zeigt dass etwa in
Berlin zum Stichtag 16 Dezember bei nur
47% der gemeldeten Fälle kovid der
Hauptgrund war 24 Prozent waren aus
anderem Grund im Krankenhaus bei 29 %
Lack keine Angabe vor in anderen
Bundesländern sieht es ähnlich aus in
der Frage wie viele Menschen aufgrund
von Omegon ins Krankenhaus müssen wird
die hospitalisierungsrate wohl wenig
belastbar sein
Beispiel zwei Impfstatus bei
Neuinfektionen ob ein infizierter
ungeimpft ist oder nicht das wissen die
Behörden oftmals nicht trotzdem erklärt
Hamburgs Bürgermeister im November von
unseren
3.452 Neuinfektionen in dieser
Kalenderwoche sind über 90 Prozent
Infektionen bei Personen ohne fallen
Impfschutz auf die Kleine Anfrage einer
Hamburger FDP-Abgeordneten schickt der
Senat dann aber folgende Zahlen bei
62,9% war der Impfstatus zu dem
Zeitpunkt gar nicht erfasst nur
14,3% waren ungeimpft
auch Bayerns Ministerpräsident hat mit
falschen Zahlen Politik gemacht twittert
im November über eine ungeimpften
Inzidenz von 1469 Zahlen heute zeigen
dass in diese inzidenzfälle mit
unbekanntem Impfstatus eingerechnet
wurden die Inzidenz der ungeimpften lag
bei
333,8 weder Söder noch Tschentscher
stehen für ein Interview mit Berlin
direkt zur Verfügung die
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der FDP
spricht von einem unhaltbaren Zustand
das ist ein Vertrauensverlust und da
müssen wir sehr schnell tätig werden
dass wir drei Kategorien haben also wer
ist geimpft wer ist ungeimpft und bei
wem ist der Status unklar dann haben wir
klare Zahlen und dann können wir darauf
auch unsere Politik ausrichten ihre
Politik aber richtet auch die Ampel noch
an unklaren Zahlen aus die
tagesaktuellen Zahlen zum Impfstatus von
Intensivpatienten die sie in Auftrag
gegeben hat werden erst Mitte Januar
vorliegen und wir brauchen dort ein
Maximum an Transparenz und an Stringenz
wenn wir das Vertrauen der Menschen
zurückgewinnen wollen beziehungsweise
behalten wollen und da ist es meines
Erachtens nicht verantwortbar wenn Mitte
Dezember ein klarer Auftrag erteilt ist
und im Januar die Datenlage nicht klar
ist
valide Daten werden dringend gebraucht
jeder Fehler jeder Fehlalarm jede
Verzerrung ist Wasser auf die Mühlen der
Skeptiker sie kosten Vertrauen und
Legitimation es geht um evidenzbasierte
Politik im Jahr 3 der Pandemie
[Musik]